intentemos encontrar la inversa de esta
matriz de 2 x 2
más adelante vas a ver que las matrices
de 2 por 2 son las únicas para las
cuales es agradable encontrar la matriz
inversa pero para éstas es muy padre
encontrar a su matriz inversa aquí nada
más lo único que tenemos que hacer es
poner uno entre el determinante
de la matriz hada y eso a multiplicarlo
por la matriz de adjuntos de la matriz a
a la cual denotamos x
esta cosa ok entonces empecemos por
calcular el determinante de la matriz a
y para calcular el determinante de a
pues hay que recordar que lo que
hacíamos es ver las dos diagonales y
multiplicar 3 por 2 y luego restarle la
otra diagonal restarle menos 7 por 5 ok
entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es
multiplicar 3 por 2
es por 2 y luego restarle muy importante
de su de restarle la multiplicación de
estos dos números o sea la
multiplicación de menos 7 por 5 menos 7
por 5 y bueno en realidad sólo te estoy
diciendo cuál es la mecánica que es
cuáles son los pasos a seguir porque
desafortunadamente así es como tenemos
que empezar más adelante vamos a verlo a
fondo pero por el momento nada más
tenemos que saber cómo se hace porque
eso nos va a llevar a donde tenemos que
llegar entonces pues vamos a hacer la
matriz de adjuntos de a
y la matriz de adjuntos como la
construimos esta agarramos a ah y
volteamos estos dos números o sea los
que están circulados en amarillo tal
cual los cambiamos el 2 va a estar en el
lugar del 3 y el 3 se va a ir al lugar
del 2
al menos 7 y el 5 los vamos a
multiplicar por menos 1 ok a los que
están en esta diagonal verde los
multiplicamos por menos 1 así es que
este 3 de aquí va a ir a dar al lugar
del 2 o sea va a ir por aquí luego este
2 de acá se va a ir al lugar del 3 o sea
que va a quedar en esta esquina y al 5
lo multiplicamos por menos 1 y nos queda
simplemente menos 5
y al menos 7 también lo multiplicamos
por menos uno y nos queda menos siete
por menos uno nos quedan siete entonces
aquí nos queda un 7 y esta es la matriz
de adjuntos de a entonces pues vamos a
hacer estas cuentas y la inversa de a y
aquí más bien debía haberle puesto un
menos uno puede crear por acá para que
sea igual a la inversa de a de esta
inversa de a es igual a
porque aquí el determinante pues tenemos
3 x 2 6 y después lo tenemos que restar
pero negativo con negativo nos da
positivo entonces aquí hay nada 35 o sea
41 entonces el determinante es 41
y la matriz de adjuntos es
entonces esto es igual a 2 entre 40 y 12
entre 41 menos 5 entre 41 menos cinco
entre 40 y 17 entre 40 y 17 entre 41 y 3
entre 41
entre 41 y esta tal cual esta es la
matriz inversa de esta matriz